good morning John I just recently along
with most Americans wrote the government
a big fat check because that's what life
is nothing is certain except for death
and taxes and also the speed of light in
a vacuum and actually now that I think
of it many universal constants are more
certain than death and taxes but I'm
getting ahead of myself taxes while I'm
not precisely happy to be rid of my
money am in favor of government and all
that jazz most of the 16,000 freakin
dollars that I just sent to the US
government it's gotta be used to
decrease suck in some way making sure
the people who lose their jobs don't
become immediately homeless education
for people who wouldn't otherwise be
educated in health care for people who
otherwise couldn't afford all of these
fantastic things but when it comes right
down to it not a lot of the money that I
just gave my government is gonna be used
to do cool stuff don't get me wrong I'm
totally in favor of reducing suck but
like my grandfather always said using
the great and awesome power of the
United States government to decrease
suck without ever increasing awesome is
a little bit like using the Starship
Enterprise as an interstellar shipping
barge but for people like me I am happy
to announce that deep in the budget
there are a few percentage points
dedicated to increasing Awesome for
example the money that the United States
government spends on science and
technology this is the graphical
representation of the United States
budget it's divided up and you might
think this this this maybe some of these
things are the science no no the science
is down to that little thing down there
less than half of that is my very
favorite government agency NASA now if I
magically shrunk the entire United
States budget into a dollar and then
split that dollar into 100 pennies I
still could not show you NASA's relative
budget because it would be smaller than
1/2 of a penny but despite that fact it
still is a relatively large amount of
money about 18 billion dollars and this
begs the question what is NASA doing
with all that money
besides maintaining a 5 bedroom house in
outer space that has been constantly
inhabited for over 10 years a Space
Station that provides our first
permanent foothold in space and a
literal and scientific and metaphorical
stepping off point into the exploration
of the rest of the solar system a place
where so much science has done that I
literally cannot even show you the names
of all the studies that have been done
there besides launching what amounts to
pretty much a remote-controlled SUV onto
the surface of Mars with 10 times the
scientific payload of any interplanetary
mission so far remote controlled
laboratory that will help answer
questions about Mars including whether
at once harbored life and helped her
Peris form and exploration of the Red
Planet besides creating a worthy
successor to the Hubble Space Telescope
allowing astronomers to see further than
it had ever hoped to see before and
allowing humanity a first glimpse at the
very origins of the universe a telescope
that can see thirteen point four billion
years into the past decides invited in
the private sector into the space and
destroying them patents on technologies
developed for NASA fostering the growth
of an entirely new sector of the economy
besides blazing the first artificial
satellite around Mercury sides making
air travel faster and safer and more
environmentally friendly so it's
building the first telescope capable of
capturing high-resolution x-ray images
slides adding three more climate
monitoring satellites to the already
existing fleet that will help us
understand our changing climate and how
to react to global climate change
besides creating frameworks and
technologies and challenges that will
help inspire the next generation of
engineers and mathematicians and
scientists identifying thousands of
planets outside of our solar system
apparently earth-like with liquid water
sides launching the final two Space
Shuttle missions while simultaneously
developing a new multi-purpose crew
vehicle capable of visiting not just the
orbit of the earth but possibly the Moon
and Mars and Venus and beyond and
besides being the best chance that we
have of answering fundamental questions
about ourselves and our place in the
universe asides that I guess NASA
doesn't do much with that 0.45 percent
of our tax dollars I'm happy to give my
money to NASA because I want my
government to be doing awesome things I
believe in my country's ability to be
awesome afraid that more and more we're
just focusing on maintenance and not on
the amazing things that we can do when
we combine our efforts and that really
is what government is about so thank you
to NASA for doing such great awesome and
exciting things with our money it's
strange to say this but I can almost not
wait to give you my money again in 2012
John I'll see you on Monday
you